if there's always a lighthouse then you
shouldn't be too surprised to hear that
a fallout 4 fan has recreated Columbia
from bioshock infinite as we've seen
time and time again since fallout 4s
release the settlement tools have been
put to great use but girl plays game
name the most impressive construct yet
as you'd expect it's a much condensed
version of Columbia however it uses a
similar color palette style and is
filled with plenty of Bioshock
references her character even Dawn's
Booker DeWitt outfit from infinite this
awesome settlement creation has even
caught the attention of irrational the
developer retweeted girl plays games
tweet about it she provided a list of
mods used in this creation on her
website since fallout 4 launched late
last year fans have created all sorts of
impressive settlements using the games
minecraft like creation tools we've seen
designs ranging from massive 80 80 s to
basketball courts design from amazing
trick shots for more on Fallout 4 and
all things gaming would you kindly stay
tuned to gamespot